[Musik]
meinen sie die ketten zu diesen
monströsen europa kappen sie die
verbindung zur eu
die meisten der liste nicht fehlen
aber wenn die eu und die schweiz
schikanieren würde dann würden wir sagen
moment mal das geht doch nicht
die schweiz neutral auf der schweiz hat
man nicht herum
es verbindet viele menschen in europa
das sie ein gespaltenes verhältnis zu
europa haben zum beispiel in
großbritannien und der schweiz
woher ihre skepsis gegenüber der eu
führt davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
roger helme ist mittendrin und will
nichts aus raus will dass das vereinigte
königreich aus der eu austritt
ich treffe ihn im europäischen parlament
um herauszufinden warum politiker wie er
immer öfter gewählt werden
und was das mit der schweizer
masseneinwanderung initiative zu tun
ich sah dass die schweiz ihr schicksal
in die eigenen hände nimmt und sich
nicht von außen bestimmen lässt wir in
england sind davon sehr betroffen
bei uns gibt es große sorgen über die
einwanderung viel sympathie roger helm
sitzt seit 15 jahren im parlament in
straßburg
er ist einer von sieben 166 abgeordneten
die meisten von ihnen kritisierten die
schweiz hart für ihre abstimmung
ganz anders die gruppe der
europa-skeptiker schluss mit der
europäischen diktatur über die völker es
lebe die freiheit freiheit für die
schweiz
[Applaus]
herr kollege borghezio ich verweise sie
aus dem saal
mario borghezio ist mitglied der
italienischen lega nord und gehörte zur
gleichen fraktion wieder so helmer doch
vg sie musste sie verlassen wegen
fremdenfeindlicher positionen ende mai
sind die europawahlen man geht davon aus
dass die europaskeptiker in vielen
ländern die wahlen gewinnen werden wo
andere die vorteile von einwanderung und
binnenmarkt sehen behauptet deutsche
helmer dass die eu-mitgliedschaft die
briten jeden tag 80 millionen kostet
doch helmer profitiert ganz persönlich
wie alle parlamentarier aber kommt er
bis zu 14.000 franken entschädigung pro
monat ist es nicht widersprüchlich dass
sie hier sitzen und mit reden und sich
dafür bezahlen
das höre ich immer aber ich habe mehr
verdient als ich mache ich sicher nicht
wegen des geldes
es ist ganz klar wir sind von den leuten
in unserem land gewählt um sie zu
vertreten
ich vertrete nicht die eu in
großbritannien
ich vertrete großbritannien in der eu um
mehr darüber zu erfahren will ich helm
ein paar tage in seiner heimat begleiten
im parlamentarier bus fahren wir nach
frankfurt nehmen das flugzeug nach
birmingham und dann das auto nach hause
das ist die schnellste variante dauert
aber trotzdem einen ganzen tag
das eu parlament tagt an zwei standorten
in straßburg und in brüssel
und so ist helmer an mehr als 30 tagen
im jahr unterwegs ist diese reise für
sie kompliziert und ermüdend und kann
lesen und arbeiten aber es ist eine
enorme zeitverschwendung für tausende
von leuten 1000 genauer 766 abgeordnete
und bis zu 7000 beamte und assistenten
die kosten für die steuerzahler werden
auf 250 millionen euro geschätzt es ist
eine metapher für europa niemand kann es
erklären niemand kann es rechtfertigen
das ist europa nein es hat frieden und
stabilität gebracht nach zwei
weltkriegen gebracht der friede in
europa kommt von der nato von 100000
amerikanischen soldaten in deutschland
vom gleichgewicht erschrecken
das hat den frieden gebracht es war
nicht die europäische kommission die die
berliner mauer zum einsturz brachte eine
umstrittene sicht
immerhin war es helmers landsmann
vincent george in der einst die
vereinigten staaten von europa lanciert
hatte
einen tag später im südwesten
großbritanniens der sogenannten
englischen riviera
hier startet die unabhängigkeitspartei
den wahlkampf für die europawahlen
albisgütli im vereinigten königreich
noch ist die youtube relativ unbedeutend
im nationalen parlament hat sie keine
sitze aber auf gemeinde ebene kommt sie
teilweise schon auf über 25 prozent
die masseneinwanderung die initiative in
der schweiz beschäftigt die partei
deutsche helfer bringt mich zum
parteipräsidenten schöne partei krawatte
veranstaltet england gilt ist aber
gemäss umfragen bereits der
zweitbeliebteste politiker im land für
frosch ist die schweizer abstimmung
einfach ich kann dem schweizer volk
versichern hätten wir abgestimmt wären
es nicht 50,3 prozent gewesen sondern
70,3 keine sorge würde ich sagen ihr
seid nicht allein
rasch ist ehemaliger banker roger helmer
war industrie lang
deshalb stört ihn an der eu etwas ganz
besonders die deutsche energiewende in
einer rede will die subventionen für
wind und sonnenenergie attackieren
diese zerstörten die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit europas hauptprobe
hinter den kulissen gut dass unser
standpunkt gehört wird europa politiker
merken es günther oettinger kritisiert
die energiewende
warum merkt oder der italienische
energie
er sagte die eu nennt ihn ein
industrielles massaker ist das nicht
etwas übertrieben sind zitate der junge
kommissar firmen die milliarden in
europa investierten tut das jetzt in
china indien den usa niemand bot mir
eine ölraffinerie oder eine
aluminiumverarbeitung in europa man baut
sie dort wo die energie billig ist
borlettis breakaway guten morgen schön
hier zu sein
ob sie an den klimawandel glauben oder
nicht die politik der eu führt uns in
den bankrott und kostet uns
arbeitsplätze und wohlstand
lasst uns die wahlen gewinnen
meine damen und herren hier kommt der
aktivste politiker großbritanniens
mister gesunde menschenverstand
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn sie glauben dass wir unsere grenzen
schützen soll
wenn wir die einwanderung kontrollieren
wollen wenn wir nicht nur quantitative
kontrolle haben wollen sondern auch
qualitative sowie australien
dann stimmen sie you kid am 22 bei
englands regierung rechnete mit einigen
10.000 einwanderern pro jahr gekommen
sind seit der personenfreizügigkeit mit
osteuropa eineinhalb millionen
die unabhängigkeitspartei verlangt dass
die briten darüber abstimmen können
wie in der schweiz kennt passt aus
eigener erfahrung was ich an der schweiz
machte war die lokale mitbestimmung dass
die menschen über die zuwanderung
entscheiden können nicht sie aussperren
aber wenn sie eine arbeit hatten und zur
wirtschaft beitragen konnten sie sich
verbessern
mein rat an die schweizer ist bestimmt
selbst klar ich bin ein judith aktivist
aber hier in england versuchten uns die
franzosen über jahrhunderte zu
übernehmen die deutschen versuchen ist
zweimal gott sei dank ohne erfolg jetzt
versuchen sie es nicht mehr mit panzern
sondern mit der politik feuerland ist
euer land arbeitet mit anderen zusammen
wir tun es auch mit dem rest von europa
du kannst es sehr gut haben mit einem
nachbarn aber du fragst sie nicht jeden
morgen was du tun sollst
viele mitglieder youtube.com laster
konservativen partei den tories
premierminister david cameron hat ihnen
versprochen dass er die
personenfreizügigkeit einschränken will
doch daran glauben sie nicht bereits
würden 70 prozent der gesetze in brüssel
gemacht
auch roger helmer früher ein teuer
konservativer hat deshalb die partei
gewechselt
er und sprach von jetzt die radikale
lösung
das ist unrealistisch wir wollen eine
scheidung eine schnelle freundliche und
dann eine handelsbeziehung dann werden
viele andere länder folgen
vorerst bleibt das rhetorik
roger helmer lebt in mittelengland in
der britischen provinz hat in cambridge
mathematik studiert und war dann 30
jahre manager in großfirmen
er glaube an wettbewerb sagt er mir die
regulierungswut brüssels führe zu
arbeitslosigkeit und verschuldung
helmer hat 15 jahre lang in asien
gearbeitet
er sagt es gebe auch märkte außerhalb
der eu
es gab eine debatte darüber ob ein teil
der schweiz isolationistische oder
fremdenfeindlich sei wegen der
masseneinwanderung initiative das fand
ich außergewöhnlich in einem land gibt
es viele themen von der verfügbarkeit
von wohnraum bildung gesundheit
öffentliche dienste die frage welche art
von migranten man will und was sie zum
wohlstand beitragen kein land kann
einfach offene grenzen haben und
unendlich menschen aufnehmen
[Musik]
sonntagmorgen bei northampton british
midlands hier lebt helmer mit seiner
frau die beiden kinder sind ausgezogen
auf dem stalldach sonnenkollektoren aber
dazu später
helmers frau ist springreiterin in den
bestellen haben sie zwei pferde
[Musik]
welchen einfluss hat die herkunft auf
das politische denken was ist für helme
heimat ich liebe mein land wie viele
andere aber wichtig ist mir vor allem
die landschaft die geschichte und kultur
[Musik]
ein dichter sagte nur ein seelenloser
der nie gesagt hätte das ist meins mein
heimatland aus diesem sinn für identität
kommt der wunsch nach selbst und so
steht helm am sonntagmorgen um 10 uhr
auf einem parkplatz und trifft seine
parteikollegen zwei monate vor den
europawahlen verteilt sie jetzt jede
woche flugblätter um die kandidaten und
ihre themen bekannt zu machen
[Musik]
das interesse scheint noch etwas gering
an diesem sonntagmorgen
was hingegen auffällt sind die vielen
sonnenkollektoren auf den dächern roger
helmer scheint hier mit seiner position
ziemlich allein zu stehen
aber er bleibt dabei wir glauben nicht
dass die erneuerbaren energien irgendein
problem lösen
deswegen bekommt für sie aber sie haben
ja selbst kollektoren auf dem dach und
profitieren
ja ich profitiere aber wenn mir die
regierung geld schenken will dann nehme
ich es ich habe die solarzellen wegen
den subventionen nicht um den planet zu
retten und im europaparlament stimme ich
immer gegen solche subventionen
[Musik]
helme redet klartext und hat seine
parolen gut eingeübt das ist ein ruhiges
quartier wo ist das ausländerproblem es
gibt kein direktes problem mit leuten
aus osteuropa die hier einziehen
aber die emigration schafft druck auf
die sozialhilfe die mieten die schule
den verkehr
das sieht man überall nur zwölf prozent
ausländer wir haben 23 in der schweiz
kann die schweiz nicht beurteilen aber
hier ist es ein riesen thema noch größer
als das eu thema
ich bin mitglied des europäischen
parlaments
wir verteilen flugblätter von judith
wollen sie an unserer veranstaltung
kommen ok
[Musik]
northampton mein letzte wahlkampftag mit
helm und lokalen kandidaten gegenseitige
stärkung mit argumenten gegen die eu
basars der eu hinein in die welt heißt
eine studie der unabhängigkeitspartei
sie zeigt die wirtschaftliche lage von
ländern die nicht mitglied der eu sind
schau mal wie erstaunlich länder die
nicht in der eu sind aber in die eu
exportieren
ich hätte nie gedacht dass die schweiz
nummer vier ist nach china russland und
den usa drei riesen länder und dann die
schweiz relativ kleines das könne auch
großbritannien schließlich war man
einmal eine globale handels macht das
ziel für die europawahlen ist die
sitzzahl partei zu verdoppeln
ich bin einer der kandidaten
es geht um die europawahl ein flugblatt
wenn sie wählen
ich bin aus litauen
arbeiten sie
die jetzt nicht dich suchen job
wie lange sind sie schon hier neun jahre
ja aber ich habe meistens mit kollegen
aus polen gearbeitet mein englisch ist
nicht sehr gut
wollen sie in england bleiben oder
zurück nach litauen
wissen sie vor einem jahr wäre ich
geblieben
aber wenn ich jetzt lese dass eine
million rumänen kommen könnten und die
löhne sinken bin ich nicht mehr sicher
nur wenige passanten lassen sich auf ein
gespräch mit der jupiter kritische
fragen kommen von einem reporter der bbc
die einen sind sie fremdenfeindlich
leute die ausländer hatten und sie sind
einfach gegen alles vor allem gegen
alles was aus der eu kommt ohne
besonders gut informiert zu sein denn es
gibt auch belege dass großbritannien
viel geld von der eben erhält ein
austritt des königreichs saß der eu ist
unwahrscheinlich auch wenn die
europaskeptiker im mai tatsächlich die
wahlen gewinnen aber vor fünf oder zehn
jahren war der austritt aus der eu ein
ferner traum jetzt ist es im mainstream
der englischen politik es ist eine
ernsthafte debatte
das wollen denn wenn es eine diskussion
gibt dann ist die position die eu zu
verlassen
viel stärker als die zu bleiben ob die
briten dann auch darüber abstimmen
dürfen darüber wird gerade heiß
debattiert
[Musik]